ecco allora io vengo da
ma questo paesino qua è un paese di
circa 4 mila abitanti in provincia
all'estremo sud della basilicata confine
con la calabria è un paese dove io sono
cresciuto e che ha una caratteristica
pensa un po particolare gli abitanti
hanno una sorta di generosità innata una
un'innata tendenza all'accoglienza che
ne ha fatto forse anche per questo un
gioiello del turismo della basilicata e
questo e panorama che io diciamo a
seconda le stagioni chiaramente qua
innevato vedo tutti i giorni da casa e
che sin da piccolo mi ha in qualche modo
ispirato per cui ovviamente ha bisogno
di un posto così non potevo che
interessarmi alla natura agli animali
alle piante e poi col tempo guarda caso
questo posto è anche diventato un parco
nazionale che su quella montagna a
destra boscosa c'è un pezzo di foresta
che dall'anno scorso è stata
riconosciuta come patrimonio dell'unesco
e quindi cioè crescere un contesto del
genere non si può che non diciamo in
qualche modo appassionarsi alla
conoscenza e la natura e questo sempre
più navigato che questo albero tipico
del parco nazionale pollino che vive in
italia esclusivamente nel pollino di cui
l'anno scorso hanno trovato un esemplare
dei 1300 anni che è l'albero più pare
insomma più vecchio d'europa come
lattazione diciamo ufficiale però col
tempo
io avevo sotto gli occhi qualcos'altro
cioè nella mia comunità nel mio
villaggio ma non solo il mio in molti
altri villaggi circostanti
nell appennino lucano e calabrese c'è
una manifestazione sacra molto
importante che chi viene chiamato il
rito arboreo la festa dell'abete il
maggio di accettura comiche
probabilmente chi è lucano ha già
sentito nominare che praticamente sono
delle manifestazioni imponenti e alla
quale partecipa tutta la comunità e per
tutto intendo tutto cioè sui quattromila
abitanti rotonda non c'è una persona che
in quei giorni non sia in qualche modo
influenzato dall esistenza di questa
manifestazione anche chi c'è al bar con
il giorno e chiuse perché tanto nessuno
andrà a prendere un caffè perché stanno
tutti in montagna insomma per intende
seguire qualcosa che in qualche modo
impegna tutti e per farvi capire questo
è l'abbattimento di un albero che
banalmente è una cosa che una persona un
operaio fa da solo con una motosega
finisce la non portargli a pezzi lo
porta via
che invece qua ci sono centinaia di
persone che assistono a questo momento
con preghiere canti
libagioni e così via se vogliamo vedere
come è fatta questa festa semplificando
diciamo come potrebbe vederlo un turista
un antropologo che viene diciamo a
visitare il pollino e partecipa a questa
festa cosa vera ma da uno o più gruppi
di persone riunite in comunità che
abbattono principalmente un grosso
faggio che si chiama apito in dialetto
cioè l'abete perché la beta si è estinto
e quindi oggi chiuso il faggio e questo
albero viene trasportato verso il centro
abitato qua siamo a invece siamo a un
paese che conoscete sicuramente
castelmezzano certo stesso rito quindi
si usa i buoi per trascinare gli alberi
ci sono momenti in cui questo albero
viene spostato con la forza delle
braccia poi pare che insomma un certo
punto qualcuno abbia detto che questa
festa rappresentava il matrimonio degli
alberi si usa diciamo innestare sulla
punta di questo grosso tronco una la
chioma di un albero sempreverde che nel
caso e polline un abete in altre zone
può essere agrifoglio
un pinot nero comunque un sempre verde e
poi questo albero viene incalzato nella
piazza del paese è questo qua diciamo è
il risultato finale giusto prima che
l'albero è stato piantato perfettamente
che resta poi a seconda dei casi ad
avere ancora altre funzioni che vedremo
dopo
e questa festa avviene tutti gli anni
come ho detto coinvolgere un sacco di
gente con ruoli diversi e è praticamente
tutti a un certo punto si sono chieste
insomma questa festa da dove
da dove arriva qual è la l'origine
l'hanno portata i normanni longobardi e
tradizioni celtiche sentire insomma sono
sentite le diverse versioni diverse
diverse ipotesi su come questa festa sia
nata e si sia diffusa nel nostro
appennino e quindi insomma stimolato e
proprio da questa festa del certo punto
mi sono insomma cominciato a informare a
documentare a cercare informazioni e ho
scoperto che ad esempio questa festa il
testo più antico che parla della vita al
povero tone del 1700 quindi niente di
nuovo ma tutto fa pensare che questa
festa sia ancora più antica
probabilmente precristiana questa perché
la zucca di halloween
perché da un certo punto cercando
informazioni sulle tradizioni le nostre
tradizioni locali e mi sono reso conto
che noi abbiamo perso forse il 99 per
cento del patrimonio culturale
tradizionale inerente le manifestazioni
religiose e profane che cade khaled che
calendarizza vano le nostre leno in i
mesi nel mondo soprattutto agricolo e
non a caso insomma perché ho messo a
zucca perché l'esempio più eclatante
cioè oggi tutti halloween è di origine
celtica e a nonna mi raccontava che
quando era piccola vedeva le persone che
andava una notte dei morti al cimitero
con l'al con un lumino fatto sonno zucca
con dentro una candelina e quindi una
festa è una festa una tradizione che
apparteneva a tutti gli effetti alla
nostra cultura così come per esempio in
occasione della sempre delle feste e
morte si usava dare la possibilità alla
gente di andare a prendersi le castagne
nei boschi privati oppure nel caso dei
funerali
c'era assistenza ai familiari per
settimane si portavano viveri si
facevano diciamo le mansioni della
masseria venivano curate dai parenti dai
vicini di casa e tutte cose che oggi
piano piano col tempo si sono andate
sono andate dal perdendosi così come
anche l'uso della visita si andava
diciamo appena salutare i parenti si
portavano sempre dei doni dei doni a
perdere
mi sono reso conto che in sostanza a
parte alcune feste come acqua sono a
montescaglioso contro vince matera con
le feste carnevale che ancora resistono
a questa diciamo perdita generalizzata
abbiamo altre feste tipo questa una
delle prime che diciamo documentato mi
interessava mi incuriosiva la figura
dell'orso come legame con la conoscenza
che nel territorio lucano nel passato
nei secoli passati dovesse ancora all
orso e questa figura esisteva ancora
nell'immaginario delle persone che ogni
anno facevano questo rito tradizionale
questo carnevale tradizionale queste qua
vicino a potenza satriano e vomito anche
questo cioè la basilicata è stata una
regione che è stata diciamo usata da chi
voleva ritirarsi a vivere in vita
eremitica e quindi questa figura del
romito che da qualcuno che viveva nei
boschi è rappresentata in un carnevale
abbiamo poi preso i falò è uno dei più
famosi falò e quello che si fa san
giuseppe e tuttora si fa occasione di
raccolta di della ginestra si fanno
queste grandi peer e il fuoco durante la
festa si balla si mangia sempre con le
offerte dei partecipanti ma mia nonna
miei nonni antenati mi raccontavano che
arrotonda in occasione di san giovanni
si faceva un falò e che consisteva nel
bruciata della legna in una piazza del
paese è poi camminare sulle braci
ardenti cosa di cui mai le nuove
generazioni diciamo non sanno più niente
interessante
tornando al discorso che ho detto prima
della generosità innata che c'è nelle
nostre comunità e in occasione di san
giuseppe
questa è una tradizione si è persa negli
ultimi dieci anni
c'era l'uso di andare settimane prima
del giorno di san giuseppe
nelle campagne casa per casa a chiedere
la gente dei beni di prima necessità che
premesse farina uova legumi e così via
uova e queste poi venivano lavorate per
realizzare un banchetto gigantesco cioè
alla quale partecipavano migliaia le
persone gratis mangiando abbondantemente
in occasione della festa di san giuseppe
non veniva chiesto niente nessun
contributo economico cioè era tutto
qualcosa di spontaneo che guarda caso
questo si fa a marzo non vi non lontano
da dove veniva questa tradizione nel
1806 avvenuta una battaglia napoleonica
e andando a leggermi quale poteva essere
l'alimentazione soldato napoleonico era
lo stesso piatto di tagliolini fatti con
le uova con i ceci quasi come queste
persone in passato avesse avuto emulare
diciamo il velo e vettovagliamento
militare alla quale avevano assistito
questo è un altro piatto che non
troverete mai nei ristoranti ma ormai
non troverete neanche nelle case delle
persone nei giorni vicino all'ascensione
i rotondese si spostavano le campagne
andavano a mendicare diciamo così un
un po di latte di capra che poi veniva a
portare a casa si realizzava questo
piatto che era un piatto a base di
tagliatelle cotte nel latte quindi
questo continuo scambio di doni che
aveva a veniva continuamente cioè il
questo senso del dare qualcosa sia per
un momento rituale sia per un momento
semplicemente confidenziale con il
vicinato era continuo un cosiddetto
baratto aperte io ti do poi riceverò
questa caratteristica quella era la
festa madonna del pollino questo è un
piccolo e caso in cui ho fatte
dell'immagine prima scarnificato pare
che insomma si usava andare alla festa
della madonna pollino anche di questo è
difficile trovare traccia si prendevano
dei bastoncini di legno ricavate dalle
pillole caso che si offrivano come
lumino sì che questa altra immagine
interessante si vede un signore che sta
vendendo un gallo praticamente in
occasione delle feste soprattutto le
della madonna si raccoglievano sempre
nelle campagne dei beni di prima
necessità vino animali conigli e poi
queste venivano venduti all'asta quindi
è un continuo scambio di doni
quindi tornando alla festa del
nella beta è un certo punto io ho
pensato che questa festa
la chiave di lettura di questa festa
doveva essere quella di una grande
diciamo offerta una grande donazione
cioè gli abitanti i nostri villaggi in
un contesto ambientale ricco pieno di
foreste e acqua
però senza beni di prima necessità cioè
senza con i beni di prima necessità a
disposizione ma in carenza diciamo di
altre fonti di ricchezza cosa potevano
fare in occasione di una festa
importante padronale fare un'offerta
alla cittadinanza che allora tutti
magari chi poteva col asino con l'eco i
boy
davano in montagna prendevano un altro
tagliavano e lo offrivano alla comunità
quindi a mio avviso leggere questa festa
con un rito particolare di origine
celtica normanna lascia il tempo che
trova
ma non si tratta altro che in un grande
diciamo di una grande offerta lati
votiva la quale partecipa tutta la
comunità che mano mano si sono
organizzati e quindi c'è chi taglia
l'albero perchè da fare quello che
porterà i buoi per il trasporto questa è
la cima dell'albero del rotonda della
rocca che trasportava in questo modo
particolare ci sono le manovalanze che
stanno diciamo lavorare il legno e
quindi fare tutti i singoli interventi
necessari e sparita l'immagine chi ha i
buoi portava i buoi che servivano a
trascinare il tronco e in questo
contesto in cui migliaia quasi migliaia
di persone si muovono c'era bisogno
anche chiaramente vettovagliamento che
quindi non era massima estro lascia chi
non aveva i buoi chi non era capace di
tagliare un albero poteva intervenire ad
esempio suonando preparando il cibo
questo famoso pagnotta di 2 chili e
passa a vip e farcita con la frittata
era un bene da portare per il
sostentamento di chi faceva questa
operazione che durava una settimana
circa andare in montagna tagliare
l'albero portato giù questo era un pane
particolare fatto con le uova che veniva
distribuito a chi comunque lavorava
durante questa settimana in modo molto
intenso per il trasporto tronco questo è
il momento in cui john questo tronco
finalmente arriva in paese quindi ci
sono anche l'autorità che prendono in
consegna questa offerta votiva
che questo questo grosso tronco
qui c'è il momento in cui questo tonco
viene donato alla chiesa a sant'antonio
in questo caso arrotonda questi sono
altrettanti che vengono donati ad altre
persone che contribuiscono in questo
modo la festa con che poi vengono
utilizzate per sollevare il tronco
principale e non è finita qua che una
volta pianta ii tronco a tutto tondo ad
esempio questa tradizione pensano altri
paesi il tipo castelsaraceno si fa
ancora si mettono dei premi sopra
l'albero
ognuno può offrire quello che gli pare
anche una bevuta al bar una volta si
appendevano addirittura gli animali vivi
e poi si usava ad esempio i cacciatori
sparare i premi quindi tentare di
portarli giu
oppure dopo se non c'erano riusciti cioè
in alcuni scalatori che rischiano la
vita per per recuperare questi premi
allora a un certo punto quando io ho
realizzato che tutta questa festa non
era altro che una positiva tentativo di
offrire qualcosa di partecipare con dei
beni donare qualcosa alla collettività
la comunità mi sono reso conto che
esistono delle comunità studiate agli
entro pollici che si chiamano che sono
basati sulla economia del dono cioè
delle comunità che non fanno altro che
scambiarsi continuamente dei beni e
rotonda forse tutto questo a rotonda nel
paese vicine non è altro che diciamo
ciò che rimane di questo modo di vivere
basato sullo scambio continuo a perdere
ripeto senza sperare in un ritorno ma
nella speranza che se io ho donato poi
in futuro ricevo io partecipo donando
riceverò non so quando ma riceverò per
cui addirittura ad esempio l'atto finale
la vendita dei tronchi avviene un'asta
dove si vendono i tronchi ma
ma laino castello assistito all'asta
vendevano poi di tutto anche una birra e
pur di donare queste birre venduto
all'asta venivano vendute a 20 30 40
euro l'uno perché era un modo anche
quello per donare ulteriormente qualcosa
che serviva al benessere della
collettività e così via
quando ho realizzato
diciamo che dietro questa festa
fondamentalmente era solo già questo
grande questa grande opera di donazioni
di generosità di e che un giorno
accompagnando la festa di sant'antonio
di rotonda e ho chiesto un signore che
portava questo barriere di vino di se
voleva la salita insomma se potevo dare
una mano ha dato e quindi l'ho portato
io quando siamo arrivate nel posto dove
si faceva colazione
mi sono avvicinato a lui gli ho detto a
chi lo devo dare di chi è questo barile
e mi ha detto mi ha risposto è di tutti
cioè non era suo non era di nessuno era
qualcosa bisognava portare che tutti
avrebbero usato e lì mi sono ricordato
che variamente nel xvii secolo tra
rotondo e castelluccio hanno trovato un
vaso ceramico una cosiddetta o la bolla
del mercoledì era era conservata al
museo di berlino dove c'è questa scritta
in carattere greci sostanza che non si
capisce cosa c'è scritto perché la
lingua e la lingua osca e notrica quella
che insomma veniva parlata prima
dell'invasione lucana nell'area nella
nostra area è l'unica parola che si
capisce una parola che è stata tolta che
significa proprio di tutti questo un po
mi ha illuminato mi ha fatto capire in
qualche modo che
sostanzialmente questa quest'aula forse
rappresenta diciamo le prime tracce del
fatto che i nostri villaggi fossero dei
villaggi delle comunità che
appartenevano a queste comunità del dono
queste comunità che basavano la loro
economia sullo scambio continuo di doni
reciproco senza nessun vantaggio
questo modo di essere è incredibilmente
sopravvissuto fino ad oggi anche se
abbiamo perso molte di quelle tradizioni
di cui ho accennato prima è passato
indenne è passato indenne attraverso
l'invasione di popoli provenienti dal
sud come gli arabi da nord come i
normanni
c'è ed è arrivato fino ai nostri giorni
e quindi tornando lasciamo al tema che
della serata
questo modo di essere stato secondo me
vincente perché ha superato indenne
almeno 2500 anni di storia
grazie
[Applauso]